you want to see something cool was it or
wasn't it cg
from the hovercrafts to flipping cars to
a fully built and then entirely replaced
set the atom project knew how to make
the best of their special and practical
effects
number one
the fights were real cg just made them
better one of the most complicated
fights choreo wise was when zoe kravitz
and ryan reynolds were reunited and
battling side by side with the trusty
blue screen behind them to touch up the
image in post when reynolds needed his
lightsaber sorry his mag sill cg took
care of the magic making him look as
slick as he was acting while cg replaced
their bodies and tech on set those
actors battling reynolds really were
suited up in tough and futuristic
looking gear
number two
it wasn't always safe but they pulled it
off the set was stunts galore and
everyone took part even newcomer walker
skoble who got up close and personal
with a harness and wires that allowed
him to safely land his first superhero
pose it wasn't so glamorous for the
other adam who straight up dealt with a
rough car smack
number three
little adam says it best that was
awesome kravitz may have pulled the
trigger boom
but it was the vfx specialists who made
the explosions we see next level just
because cg was playing a part didn't
mean the team was going to skip out on
the chance to use a real car for their
stunt though the effects just cleaned
the image up blue screens were all
around the giant practical set giving
the actors space to perform the intense
choreo they worked on for months while
cg brought the fire wherever and
whenever needed
number four shockingly a ton of the
chase scene isn't cgi
that's right
fifty percent of what we see on screen
throughout the big chase fight was one
hundred percent really done and that
included the hovercraft racers and i
said can we actually do that for real
luckily the answer was yes we surfed
these guys through the woods in british
columbia sitting inside the truck
zooming through the woods did involve a
truck racing not so much you guys shot
on a green screen stage in a truck in
front of green screen and then there's
the whole launching out of the ship
moment that happened completely in
studio with performers rigged up safely
in front of a special blue screen and
hooked up to a real hoverboard except
for this shot the boards took a backseat
and let the vfx team do the heavy
lifting
number five we're talking sorian style
it's called a mag look it up you can't
cause it's not real they may be sorian
weapons but these intricate and
fascinating looking tools were actually
created by a small company called super
vixen all the way down under in
australia
i feel like there's that basic thrill of
seeing something you haven't seen before
all the design pieces were 3d printed
and put together no easy feat
considering there were over 200 pieces
to put together in total for the scene
that sees weapons and tools flying
through the air the visual effects team
use the custom design tools as a base
and then mock them up digitally for the
final edit
number six
what you see isn't always what you get
or is it i told the vfx team i need some
kind of program that allows me to see
the virtual set the high-tech and
spacey-looking office was a totally
constructed set in a giant blue studio
one that allowed the actors to really
immerse themselves in the world and
technology it's really opened up shot
design possibilities in a real way and
from angles that i can't even get to
mark ruffalo made sure to take advantage
of the fact that he could actually
interact with the set while all the
detail was great for the actors to work
with it wasn't totally up to scratch for
the final edit so the whole lab was
digitally replaced in post but based on
the design that was built in real life
number seven
spontaneously appearing aircraft no
biggie but really first of all none of
that was there you heard her say it no
real spacecrafts were harmed in the
making of this film since there were no
ships to be harmed the skies were all
clear so the editing team had a solid
base to bring the ship to life via cg
and a pretty wicked looking one at that
let's just go home please
number eight
we've never seen catherine keener
looking like this before
and hopefully we won't again considering
what we got on screen was not at all a
true-to-life version of a younger keener
this deep fake didn't totally work out
as instead of relying on makeup and
prosthetics the actress was given a cg
face put over top her actual face making
for some seriously uncanny valley vibes
i fixed that future de-aging is tricky
but we definitely prefer keener without
the cg
then why are you back here now
aside from the one cg face misstep the
special effects team for the atom
project went above and beyond to elevate
this film to the next level caught up
the atom project did you think all the
hovercraft action was full cg2
who knew